if you if you if you want to hit like a
dude then get pre then be prepared to
get slapped like a dude like i think so
if one of you
if you went up if you went up to the
rock okay yeah and you hit him yeah and
then you get decked back yeah nobody's
going to feel it i have to hold you yeah
right i'll have to hold it
but people will say to you you shouldn't
have hit the rock but you're hitting the
rocket back yeah you're the antagonist
right and so i'm saying like like if a
girl if it's the arguments like the
girl's weaker but there are guys that
are are skinnier than other guys or like
smaller than other guys like the rock is
gonna beat up any dude in this room and
if any of you hit him you're stupid for
doing that yeah just like a woman like
i'm sorry you're gonna hit like a dude
you should get you prepared to get him
in that situation as a guy you're kind
of taught from a very young age
depending on your upbringing that even
if that happens you have to almost be
the bigger person yeah yeah and not
strike back yeah but that's what you
talk about you can defend yourself
without like going him yeah
i would say yeah that
the way how
like i've been brought up and not how i
bring up my son is if a girl hits you
you go and get your sister i make your
sister demolish her
okay
the other day they was playing outside
and my son coming crying said that
someone slapped him in the face i said
you know what you got to do you beat her
ass
and ever since the dawn of time like i
can't lie ever since i've known like
when a girl wants to put her hands on me
or even just chat [ __ ] to me bro i'll go
call one of my ratchet hoes bro from the
um yeah one of the girls that man knows
and just tell them yo i can't i got a
problem with this girl yeah pissing me
off bro yeah sort that out please see my
brother's never had that problem because
i'm mentally unstable
oh man but um yeah i kind of feel like
it should be dealt with in the moment
though
no you know we've seen it being dealt
with in the moment with the whole like
chris brown rihanna thing
that got dealt with in a moment and look
what happened to chris brown
[Music]
that's that's why in the last show when
you were saying the guy should hit back
i i understand that but if he does and
he gives into the range one punch is
going to turn into this
that's the problem is that like if you
guys do then you guys get in trouble but
i'll fight for your rights
i'll march the streets yeah
because you just keep going and going
and going there's no gauge because
you've been holding it up the whole time
and when you explode you explode
but why do you think it is in society we
have this initial inclination to believe
women like regardless of their
credibility
like
i don't think women are believed i don't
think they are because that's like black
victims
say grape say grape sorry like i
wouldn't say that they are almost like
always believed because that's about
like not a lot of grape
trials yeah make it to court and then
now when it comes to great i feel like
that's that's different because
equally the women could be lying and
there's no way to verify who's lying
who's telling the truth whereas with the
domestic violence you can tell that
there's no with domestic violence the
woman's black and blue yeah
with grape it's like well with grape you
need evidence
and yeah and a lot of
a lot of the cases are thrown away right
or ignored it's not necessarily women
aren't believed it's that like in order
to convict someone you need evidence
that they did it and if you don't
provide that
but even in this like scenario we're
assuming that the girls that can't prove
it are telling the truth yeah like they
could be lying we don't know but if you
don't have evidence to back it up like
yeah i feel like women would believe the
100 like if it was me if my sister
called me and said it's tricky and said
such and such with my with my ex or with
my man or whatever i'm going to believe
her immediately it's just that's your
sister though even if it's about even if
it was a stranger on the road i'm just
going to believe i'm not going to take
action but my instinct is just your
inner thought is to believe you know
what i mean like i thought that means i
think it depends on what you know though
right so if you knew that your sister
lied a lot and she called you yo you'll
be like no that's what i'm saying if
even if it was a stranger on our way
back now if you see a woman running
asking for help yeah saying the guy's
done this we're not going to be like
yeah but did he we're in this yeah
are you sure
so what did you do
some people do say what do you do yeah
yeah true yeah but women take advantage
of that like they i i think there's
certain women that know that
that's the club
you asked any girl about her ex oh he
was so toxic he was the word like it's
never what they did wrong the guy is
always the bad guy yeah no i take
accountability i say like i used to have
this problem with my ex that
might women would get into it
like the way he would tell the story oh
she's crazy she done x y and z to me but
then when i told a story okay this is
what happened we was chilling and then
he done x y and z so then i got my car
and ran him over
wait wait you got your car and you ran
them over yeah that but what the reason
why wait was because
the reason why
was because he done something to me
first so because
okay what did he do what did he do
what did he do yeah to get ran over like
a car doesn't matter doesn't matter the
fact is he started it yeah yeah i'm
gonna tell you what he did i'm gonna
take it he put his hands on me in it and
i knew i wasn't in a position to fight
him
but because he put his hands on me and
it hurt me i needed to hurt him back so
i decided to hurt him in the car
fair enough was he good was he good like
did he live yeah it wasn't at high speed
definitely lived he literally just uh
flew up into the air he came down again
was it four by four
no it was a polo it was his polo
actually
i have a question
does everyone believe her
i do you know i kind of do i really do
this is why men don't want to hit women
back because they can get run over by
their own politics yeah no but this is
what i'm saying it's like the
at the most i've had like dishes being
dashed at me and that so i believe it
yeah jesus christ you're saying the
wrong thing yeah yeah you know good yeah
i could never
oh but then there's also been times when
i've put my hand on on a guy i'm [ __ ]
up
and then i'm just where did you did you
antagonize the guy i put my hands on him
first okay well then my hands on him
first but then but then i would sit
there and i'd be like all right cool but
you didn't have to do me like that
you didn't have to do that
no no i hear what you're saying yeah
yeah but you have to hear what i'm
saying yeah a guy here is naturally
stronger than me yeah i know so if i'm
hitting you if i'm hitting you yeah i'm
hitting you no no but the fact that you
know that yeah
i'm not justifying it what i'm trying to
say to you is it is yes that you see he
said that how one punch can turn into 20
punches when you're a female you don't
have to punch it you don't have to punch
a female 20 times so even if you wanted
to punch me once that would have been
more than enough
but no i do understand that and i i do
believe that men have like
biologically men are stronger but the
case in point is
one you shouldn't hit anyone if you
don't want to be hit rather rather they
like don't have to go all the way when
they're like retaliating
that's that's up to them but you're not
like you can't hit someone and say oh
well
i'm i'm weaker than you so don't hit me
back i get where she's coming from i've
got a couple good punches in any way
no i don't get that but i'm just saying
like like
right or wrong like you can't justify
saying like oh i'm i'm the weaker person
and not like no i think if you hit like
a dude expect to get hit by a dude like
yeah but if you're here
you'll go ahead go on i'm just saying if
i hit you three times it doesn't mean
you should hit me that's what i was
gonna say like sometimes when i play
fight with my brother uh-huh i might
poke him
and you punch me like 20 times i'm like
bro you took but you know it is it's
like a man can't see you oh you know
what to equal your one punch i got to do
a punch too
but hold on if you're perfect there's
not so much you should go for your
country sent a nuke to [ __ ] america
do you think america is going
one new map
is up to you yeah yeah you shouldn't you
shouldn't start anything you can't wait
times
you shouldn't you shouldn't start
anything you can't finish
so it's like if you if you started it
that's not
like you shouldn't hit him definitely
and if my man gave you a bang back
you'll think [ __ ] all right no no if
that bang was solid it should be knocked
you'll be out for a while you have to
take this out none of these [ __ ] have
got solid bangs
[Laughter]
still stand a [ __ ]
i feel like you are more likely to
believe
a female in that situation not saying
that women don't lie women [ __ ] lie
yeah but i think
generally speaking more men
abuse women physically than women
lie about being abused 100 percent i
think because of that you naturally give
that sort of nickname you don't believe
so no no no because you have to we have
to remember yeah no not a lot of men
were like built like us for example
i mean so saying that it's like
i'm sorry
i'm different
it's like obviously when a lot of men
know they have the physical power over
women and a lot of men are just [ __ ]
all so they can't bully man they're not
bullying girls yeah i mean okay
it's just that they take their anger out
on on their wives well i think i think i
think that like you take away the
consequences in a society more people do
it and we've eliminated consequences for
women so that's why i think more women
do it because like some dudes probably
have the capacity to hit a girl and
probably like would but they choose not
to because they don't want to go to jail
yeah yeah but like women can do that and
yeah like well like what's going to
happen if a girl hits you and you call
the police
like oh is it i've been arrested
what were you going to talk about um so
i'm going to touch on what you said
about like boys bleeding girls whatever
now i've actually got a real life
experience my daughter
she started secondary school in last
year
and um this boy in year nine has like i
would say been bullying her and um
when the teacher called me about it like
i went absolutely ballistic at him
because what he said to me was that oh i
told her not to worry about it because
he probably likes her and i said and
this is what is wrong with [ __ ]
society because how how are you
normalizing domestic abuse at 11 years
old you did you telling my daughter that
he oh don't worry about it he probably
likes you what you trying to teach my
daughter any man that likes her is going
to treat her like [ __ ]
can i touch you
i'll be honest here i was in primary
school and like this is the first time
i've ever seen this on content it's like
i had anger management when i was in
primary school in it and also girls no
no i didn't i didn't i didn't
take me out of class they'll be like all
right she it's because she fancies you
that's why she's doing that so just
ignore her brother i used to think cool
i'll ignore her she's still in my head
[ __ ] that man yeah draw me so obviously
that carried on into secondary school so
i hear what you're saying the thing it
normalizes it and i think yeah that
teachers need to stop doing that well
they they normalize abuse against men
though like i think more so than women
like for example there was um a view
clip where they were joking about
chopping a dude's like off
because he cheated and she'd like
chopped his now imagine if imagine if
like that happened to if a man did that
to a woman he chapter like tits off
because she cheated
i think it's wrong on both sides
because they've been cheating yeah yeah
when i was in jamaica when i was in
jamaica they was
they had candles all down the road and i
said to my uncle why is there so many
candles he goes oh somebody died the
move pulled over now i said oh you died
they said oh the woman
um a man catcher tech [ __ ]
there are certain cultures that will do
that even if it's not cheating even if
it's
you know
i don't think most men are out here
murdering cheaters
no but even even not like
say even in a relationship like even
when i'm on the road and stuff um
doesn't matter where i'm at if a guy's
like trying to move to me i would just
give them my information like like my
number or whatever because i value my
life and i don't know how they're going
to snap this outfit
yeah because i don't know i don't know
who you are and not saying that i can't
fend for myself but i don't know how how
far i can defend myself for one and two
i value my life over saying like oh no i
i would not like to talk to you because
after i walk away i can block you
you don't know where i live you don't
know all these things so i i rather just
say here's my info yeah okay yeah i'll
talk to you later
i'm not that i'm mad when you literally
don't know who you're talking to like
literally a guy can just step to a girl
right but that's not the rule though i
don't think most men are like killing
girls
um i don't think most men are killing
girls because they've been rejected
but that like
i do i do think so like a lot of
violence happens like when you get there
they're
they are so insecure
yeah some guys do take
they're wrong
right right but it's the exception it's
not the rules yeah true
killing and physical violence yeah right
then i think some guys just can't take
it no i'll be wrong
do you think do that what killing and
what not just killing them but any any
violence so what percent of men do you
think are violent against women oh
i think probably like 50. i think 50
percent yeah but you're saying that
you're saying no
no okay no no no i'm saying this as a
female don't it doesn't why why do we
bring up gender what like a man has an
opinion on anything it doesn't matter if
he's a man or a woman because he's not
going to be the one experiencing who
cares if he's been through an experience
is what you're saying true or untrue
like who who gives a [ __ ] if it's a dude
it's what you're saying accurate are you
saying that fifty percent of your
experiences have been violent
with a male so out of out of this group
you think half of them
yeah i've punched up a couple women in
my time still
i'm joking
this one used to throw chess at them
yeah
[Laughter]
like i would say maybe that in my
experiences with men
i think of all of the experiences that
i've had with men i think
three of them have been violent towards
me
i think
maybe
five of them have threatened violence
towards me but i've never actually been
violent
and then the rest they're just they just
take the bad up i think people are
getting intimidated so what percentage
yeah i know i've dealt with ghosts like
you like you don't know what i'm like
[Laughter]
no me saying that i'm not saying about
guys that i've been with like
because i would i would not be with
someone like that's like abusive and
obviously like no one is willing you
don't know that though no but no
no i'm saying i'm saying myself the
moment that i'm seeing that i'm gone
[Music]
for one horror story
i do know that but i'm telling you for
me
i'm gone yeah like if you have one
horror story yeah there's gonna be a
hundred or a thousand stories that
aren't horror stories but you're gonna
remember that one horror story more yeah
and it's gonna be like [ __ ] half the
guys are pricked really true but is that
what's really happening right yeah i saw
a guy move to a girl and she just didn't
want to talk to him he's like why aren't
you talking to me she's like i got a
boyfriend oh who's your boyfriend i'm
going to do this i'm going to do that
like why bro
even at the lowest level just dms bro
i've seen man move crazy just getting
internet isn't definitely you know
people get people get a lot more bolder
on the internet no but i think he's
saying in person yeah no yeah in person
but even to the lower level level which
is social media when guys don't get
responses from girls like they're
replying yo what are you ugly
what the [ __ ] bro like how do you not
even have the pride to do that i have a
stat so um
of domestic abuse crimes recorded by the
police 26 were committed against men
um and it says
half of male victims 49 failed to tell
anyone that they were a victim of
domestic abuse and are two and a half
times less likely to tell anyone than
female victims agreed
because they don't want to be seen as a
[ __ ]
yeah